I am delighted
to be here with you on this very, very special day
Dresden is without a doubt,
if I may call it that, a
digital lighthouse in Europe we are
indeed celebrating the groundbreaking ceremony
for a Smart Power
a big step forward for Dresden and
silicon Saxony but also a big
step forward for Europe
from 2026 semiconductors are to be produced here on a large scale the
region
can hope for more than 1000 sustainable
jobs and not
counting what
additional jobs will
develop from this
and that is of course first and foremost a
great perspective  for Saxony and
the whole region but it is also
extremely important news for Europe
why this is the case I would like to briefly explain to you
on my travels I often come across top
digital performance made in Europe
startups from Slovakia, for example
the new technologies on the market
bringing from nano sensors to
RNA specification and sequencing
Universities in Ireland are
using artificial intelligence to
improve animal health in agriculture A Luxembourg company
is using
quantum computers and satellite technology to develop
ultra-secure communication systems,
but Europe is not only strong in such
digital applications
our semiconductor research and
development is
recognized worldwide we build excellent
leaders of special machines for chip
production supplied from Europe all over the
world
and not only silicon sexy but also
place names have an excellent
global ring in the digital scene
if I remember a lion iMac or
Eindhoven  but with eisml on Grenoble
and Barcelona
and indeed the European
Commission, together with the
member states, is doing pioneering work in the
field of data protection and secure
artificial installed intelligence,
we can also be proud of these digital strengths of
Europe - a very clear yes,
we can be satisfied with the balance sheet
not yet because there is still a lot
more to do and this is exactly where Dresden comes
in.
The globalization push of the past
decades has meant that
the economic regions of the world have concentrated too
much on their respective strengths.
Europe, for example, has its expertise
in this area  in research and development,
as well as in
industrial applications,
which has not been a priority for a long time, however,
is the mass production of
semiconductors without which our
wheels will ultimately stand still
the global focus of our knowledge
is currently in Taiwan and South Korea
and thus in one region
in which tension could arise and
any disruption to trade would
immediately have a severe impact on Europe's strong industrial base
and our internal market,
we are all living like the geopolitical
risks have increased these days
and that is why we in Europe have to tighten the
supply chains of our most important goods and
Strengthening technologies
means that we also
have to position ourselves more broadly with chips, we
have to reserve more of our own capacities
and for the semiconductors that are so important
we need more
mass production here in Europe
and that is why, ladies and gentlemen,
Dresden is such an important milestone as
you know  that chips that are produced here
are in everything, they are in cars
in all kinds of electrical devices, but they
are also used not only
in the digital transformation but
also in the green transformation of the
power supply for wind turbines for
express trains in the local
data center June  last but
not least, these chips are an
indispensable part and
building materials of Europe's sustainable and
Europe's digital future
and therefore the focus of our
European Chips Act is on
increasing domestic production
for the European Chips Act we take
that is the European Union and
Member States up to  43 billion
euros in hand by 2030,
together with
Europe's industry, we want to double our share of global
chips production to 20% and
because the chips market is developing so rapidly,
for us that actually means
that we have to quadruple our current capacities
that can only be done in one go  close
interaction with strong companies
such as inform
the chipsakt creates planning security
for the semiconductor companies and the
suppliers
in Europe
and that is crucial because we
all know that the whole world is currently
trying
to have chip production settle in
their regions of
Dresden and  silicon Saxony are a
symbol of the fact that Europe as a business location
can definitely hold its own in this competition
if we design the framework intelligently and
it is no coincidence that Infineon is
making the largest single investment in the company's history here.
Behind the term silicon sexy lies a clever settlement policy  Cooperation
between business and science in and
around Dresden Chemnitz and Leipzig
behind it is the Engel interaction
of innovative startups and established
world market leaders
and behind it there is more than just a
pinch of Europe there are, for example, the
funds from the Corona reconstruction of
innovative, particularly energy-efficient
chips
and we have in  In the past few months,
our subsidy policy in the field of
chips has been fundamentally changed in the European
Commission and this adjustment is
now also showing initial successes using the
example of modern ones
in Sicily and the Kroll near
Grenoble
Dresden and the examples mentioned
show how we can be successful
if we do our  Strengths
and we also want success to
last and that is why we are working hard
to ensure
that Europe has access to the
necessary raw materials that
tomorrow's economy will need. We have
therefore launched the criticalsact
because we want to ensure
that the necessary rare earths and
raw materials are not running out in Europe
give you an example
silicon metal is the most frequently
used raw material for
chip production,
China currently dominates global production with 76 percent
and this dependence on a
single raw material supplier is a
risk, which is why we want to start new
projects in Europe  also
provide alternatives with partnerships with like-minded countries such as Australia, the USA or Canada and thus
secure and strengthen the supply chains of European companies,
ladies and gentlemen, for everyone who is working on
a successful digital future,
today is a very special
day, these events are an important
signal that far  radiating beyond Dresden,
I only have a vague idea of ​​the enormous
planning work and preparation that
was necessary to reach this very special
milestone, and
I would therefore like to thank all the
women and men involved in the
company and the
administration for their tireless and
excellent work from the bottom of my heart
Well done, I congratulate
Infineon, I congratulate Saxony, I am
happy for the economy in
Germany, I am happy for the
economy in Europe, may the
construction work proceed happily and well,
thank you very much
[music]